hey everyone welcome to this next
episode of your daily equation and today
I'm going to focus attention on a very
famous theorem proved by the
mathematician Emmy Noether which has
really had profound impact in physics
ever since she established his theorem
back in 1918 so here is the hero of
today's episode I mean oh they're German
mathematician born in me in the 1880s
came to prominence in the early part of
the 20th century widely recognized as
this brilliant mathematician when the
Nazis came to power in Germany she left
Germany immigrated to the United States
joined the faculty at Bryn Mawr College
I think I pronounced it right Bryn Mawr
Bryn Mawr College and she unfortunately
died at a very early age in her 50s from
from cancer tragically left us far too
soon but she proved and contributed
great many theorems to our understanding
him in mathematics in the areas of
abstract algebra
I've studied her work outside of physics
in Galois theory and mathematics but
perhaps the most famous theorem at least
to a physicist is what is known as
no--there's theorem as if there's only
one there are many but it's a theorem
that gives us insight into the
connection between conservation laws and
symmetry as well as I'll now discuss
here's a here's a little excerpt from
the paper itself as I mentioned 1918 as
you can see you know it gets kind of
heavy after a while but the essence of
no--there's result can really be
distilled into a fairly simple
formulation which of course can be
generalized but I like on as you know
I'd like to pair things down in this
series to the essence of the
mathematical idea because the
generalizations can look
far more complicated than than the
initial incarnation that for instance I
show you but those details while
important for the general application of
many of these ideas are not so important
to get the gist the essence of what the
contribution is all about so let's get
into then the subject here and let me
swap over to my iPad good so we're
talking about no there's theorem and I
know that I am pronouncing her name a
little bit wrong but it's kind of the
best that I can do maybe it's new to as
neuters theorem something like that but
it's gonna sound kind of bizarre if I
try to do that so let me just use the
standard American pronunciation of no
this theorem and the idea is this up
yeah it is up on the screen okay so so
as I mentioned it's all about the
relationship between what are known as
conservation laws and symmetries and so
let me spend just a moment on
conservation laws first then I'll get to
symmetries and then I'll show her
beautiful theorem that connects the two
all right so what is a conservation law
conservation law is any law that tells
us that a quantity doesn't change over
time I mean the most familiar
conservation law I think that we're all
familiar with is this notion of
conservation of energy you know the
energy that you begin with is equal to
the energy that you end with if you add
up all sources of energy and these
conservation laws are incredibly
powerful I mean let me just give you one
simple example that no doubt you've
encountered various versions of this in
your own studies but it's kind of good
just to see it spelled out once
especially in this context let's imagine
that we have some block
that's on a hill and maybe it's a really
complicated looking hill and the block
starts over here and it slides down this
hill imagine there's no friction so
things are really nice and imagine that
you are challenged with working out what
the speed of the block is at the bottom
of the hill now of course one way of
going about this um the most
straightforward naively is you simply
start with Newton's laws you've got F
equals MA equals M d2x
DT squared and you know the various
forces that are acting on this block
you've got the force of gravity if you
got thee the normal force that's the
force exerted by the slide along which
this block is moving so you could try to
spell these out in detail with the
vector components plug them into the
differential equation above from that if
you solve that differential equation you
could get the position as a function of
the time T given that you can take the
derivative and you evaluate it at the
time when the block gets to this
location so all very doable but a little
bit involved a far simpler way to get at
the answer is to use conservation of
energy what do I mean by that in this
particular case well at the beginning of
the blocks journey it is say at rest and
therefore all of the initial energy that
it starts with comes from gravitational
potential energy which we know now I'll
just write down here is the mass of the
block G the acceleration due to gravity
times H imagine that the height of the
block above the ground surface is H now
by conservation of energy this must also
be equal to the energy that the block
has at the end of its
when it has reached this location over
here the cauldron plaque won't change
but you know what I mean now at that
location the blog doesn't have any
gravitational potential because H is
equal to zero but it does have kinetic
energy which is one-half M times the
speed squared and then we therefore have
MGH equals one-half MV squared which
means we can solve for V multiplied to
the m/s go away and V therefore is equal
to the square root of 2gh and there we
have the answer in you know one line of
work no differential equation to solve
no F equals MA so it's a real powerful
shortcut to getting the answer to the
problem that we were looking at so
conservation laws the message of this
little example really brings home are
quite powerful let me give you one other
example just for the fun of it
let's look at conservation of momentum
so let's imagine a circumstance where
momentum is conserved and the
circumstances under which it is
conserved we are going to come to quite
shortly but I'll give an example where
it is conserved imagine I have say a
star in space and it goes supernova
imagine that this star just explodes I
can't really not good artists but you
know imagine that all these little
pieces of the star get blown outward
this one this way this one that way each
one has its own little velocity vector
and just draw a few of them so you can
get a feel for the issue I'm about to
raise which is what if I were to ask you
to do what appears to be a gargantuan
calculation what if I said to you what
is the total
final momentum of all those little
particles that the star blasts outward
into space I want you to sum over all of
those little particles the momentum of
the ice particle that is flung outward
by the star well how do you how do you
do that well you know you could try to
work out the detail force that blew the
star apart and you could try to figure
out how that force exerted and and
resulted in the motion of each little
tiny constituent that gets blown out
where you could try to do that but man
that would be tough but using
conservation of momentum there is a much
simpler way to go about it the total
momentum final must be equal to the
total momentum initial and what was the
total momentum initial well the star was
just kind of sitting there not doing
anything just imagine that the star to
be a little more precise just a solid
rock with no motion whatsoever evil just
to keep our selves simple in this
description and that initial momentum
was equal to zero overall the thing was
not moving at all and therefore the
answer to your question well not your
question my question that I asked you
that some must add up to zero and we got
that without having to do any difference
equations no F equals MA nothing
complicated at all so again it's just to
show that
conservation laws are are really
powerful they're really important okay
so then that takes us to what Emmy
Noether the profound contribution that
she gave us in 1918 and that profound
contribution as I mentioned is this
connection between symmetry on the one
hand and this important idea that we
just talking of conservation laws okay
so I've said already a few words about
conservation laws let me say a few words
therefore about symmetry and there are
two important classes of symmetry that
are good to bear in mind there are so
called continuous symmetries and there
are also what are known as discrete
symmetries so let me just give you an
example of each just to make sure that
we are all on exactly the same page and
I should should have some example I
should have set this up what can I use
um well yeah sorry all right so I do
have a ping-pong ball here and it does
have some some writing on it but ignore
the writing imagine this is just a
perfectly orange ping-pong ball with no
writing on it whatsoever if that were
the case then as I rotate it regardless
of how I rotate it it would look the
same to you again forget the writing so
the writing does break the symmetry but
if there was no writing at all however I
rotate this I'm trying to keep the
writing on my so I any rotation leaves
it looking the same and by that we mean
that the ping-pong ball has a symmetry a
symmetry is a transformation of an
object or an equation or the ingredients
that make up a physical system it's a
transformation of the system which
leaves the system looking the same or we
often say it leaves the system invariant
so this is a continuous symmetry because
I can rotate it at arbitrary angles
however little however big I have a
continuum of symmetry transformations
that I can apply to the ping-pong ball
that leave it looking the same
for for a discrete symmetry well any any
symmetric looking object can do let me
let me use my this mug that people
comment on my my dirty muddy water some
this Earl Grey with soy milk
unfortunately has tea leaves and I do
not want to turn it on the side without
drinking it so excuse me I will for you
know for science for pedagogy
let me just drink all the junk that's in
here I do not like to drink tea leaves
but whatever okay so now this is more or
less clean sorry if you found that a
little gross but so this is more or less
clean now and and you'll note that if I
look at the opening the top of this mug
I have a circle here just look at that
circle as I rotate this mug as I rotate
that circle the circle looks the same
the rest of the mug does not look the
same under that continuous
transformation of course because I mean
forget about the handle but the rest of
the mug it has a discrete symmetry by
that I mean if I rotate it by 90 degrees
it looks the same forget the handle if I
rotate it by 90 it all looks the same
because of the discrete symmetry
respected by the bulk the body of the
mug and so this is an interesting
example where I have about the
continuous symmetry part of it and I
have a discrete 90 degree four-fold
symmetry for the the rest of the mug you
know you can do this with a book you
know and why not plug my own book right
so you know here here forget about the
title of the book it's the shape I'm
after you know if I wrote today this way
it doesn't look the same the shape but
if I rotate it this way it does so I
have to rotate it by 180 degrees for the
shape to return to the form that I began
with those are discrete transformations
whoops just knock some stuff over there
you know a more pretty example let me
bring that up on the screen here so here
is a you know a prettier example that is
the canonical one that people often use
it's a snowflake so you see the
snowflake here has a six-fold symmetry
so
if you rotate it by sixty degrees each
of those points moves over to the
location occupied by the previous point
and therefore it looks the same
under that discrete six volt
transformation so you have these
discrete symmetries and you have
continuous symmetries and what no
they're found is that if you let me go
back over here if you use continuous
symmetries so everything we're going to
talk about now is focusing on the
continuous symmetry case and which is a
different color so these continuous
symmetries are related to me related to
conservation laws and that's it's that
connection that I now want to spell out
for you and it's actually in the pared
down version that I'm going to focus my
attention on it's actually a pretty
straightforward argument again as I
showed you know this paper does get
pretty involved you can take these ideas
to a great level of generalization
abstraction but to get the gist of it
you don't really need all of that so
what am I gonna do I'm going to work in
the context of Lagrangian mechanics and
if you don't know what that is then
you're gonna have to just kind of follow
along at a 30,000 foot level but if you
want to have little background on that
you can look at the episode that we had
earlier on the least action principle
where I described the basic idea of
Lagrangian mechanics I'm not gonna go
all the way back to review that here let
me just well that is a serious em that I
have there can I just erase this little
part of it yeah it's gonna get in my way
let me just do that like that so I'm
going to start with a Lagrangian which
you will recall either from your own
studies or from our previous episode say
depends on coordinates their derivative
so a dot means DX DT I could also have a
T in here but I'm going to pair it back
to
to keep things simple and imagine that
the Lagrangian is a function say of X
and X dot and then B momentum is
defining to be DL DX dot and what we
showed in an earlier episode and again
it's standard so many of you have
encountered it elsewhere is that the
equation of motion that the coordinate X
will follow will satisfy as a function
of T can be gotten by looking at D by DT
DL DX dot and said in that equal to DL
DX in essence these are or I could say
this is in this one-dimensional case and
I'm writing down this is Newton's
equation this is just Newton's law this
is F equals M a DL DX is basically F and
D by DT of DL DX dot is d by DT of P
which for constant mass is just mass
times second derivative of X with
respect to time which is MA okay so it's
a fancy way of writing F equals MA and
now what we're going to do is we are
going to imagine that there is a
transformation a continuous
transformation in which we are going to
imagine taking X and replacing it by
some transformed value of x which I'm
going to call X of lambda so lambda will
be our transformation parameter so for
instance when I was rotating the
ping-pong ball lambda could be the angle
through which I am rotating this ball
say in three-dimensional space so I'm
going to take X to be X of lambda and
I'm going to imagine that this is a
symmetry of my Lagrangian which means
that when I plug X of lambda in place of
X in my Lagrangian imagine I substitute
X of lambda for X the Lagrangian won't
change at all which means
if I now frame this in just the language
of calculus
it means if I look at D by D lambda of L
of X of lambda X dot of lambda that that
derivative will be equal to zero doesn't
change at all as a function of land that
doesn't change at all as a function of
this continuous symmetry okay so with
that as a starting point a Lagrangian
together with the continuous symmetry
what no other is able to prove is that
there is a quantity and I'm going to
give that quantity a name I don't know
maybe pink is phone a call it AI for
invariant or you call it C for conserved
it doesn't matter it's just a definition
of a letter I'm going to define this
invariant quantity to be DL DX dot
multiplied by the derivative of X with
respect to lambda and the claim is that
this quantity does not change in time it
is a conserved quantity so
mathematically then what we need to
prove to establish this is that if I
look at di DT the claim is no this claim
is that this will be identically equal
to zero it will not change in time so
that's the connection between a symmetry
as described by this continuous
transformation and this conservation law
given by this di DT identically equal to
zero statement so now what I want to do
is just give a little proof of that fact
and the proof is in this very simple
pared down version not hard to come by
at all we just really need to follow our
nose as people say so we're going to
just calculate di DT so we're going to
calculate D by DT of DL DX dot DX D
lambda
and now I'm just going to use the
product rule to work this out so this is
the same as the by DT of DL DX dot times
DX D lambda and now let me add in the
second term DL DX dot now I can put my D
by DT acting on DX by D lambda but I'm
going to assume that the symmetry
transformation does not depend upon time
again one of the little simplifications
you can more be more general as I've
said before but just to get the gist of
it we'll look at that simple case which
means I can interchange the lambda
derivative and the T derivative and I'm
going to do that I'll write this as d by
the Atlanta of D X DT okay so far so
good now what I'm going to do is oh
sorry I didn't mean to bring that full
frame sorry let me do this again so what
I'm going to do now is I'm going to
simplify or perhaps a better way of
saying it is I'm going to make use of my
understanding of the equations of motion
to substitute a different expression for
D by DT DL BX dot how do I do that well
look I'll scroll right up over here
notice that what we had before are these
equations of motion that emerge from
this least action principle this is
nothing but F equals MA in slightly
fancier language but the point for us
now is the first term D by DT D L DX dot
we can now substitute from the equations
of motion set that equal to DL DX this
guy right over here so let me do that so
I'll write this now as equal to say DL
DX times DX D lambda and then for the
second term I'll write it as d L DX dot
and using DX DT is nothing but this guy
over here is nothing but X dot this is
DX dot d lambda okay that's kind of cool
because
you will recognize this is nothing but D
by DT of L of X and X dot because by the
chain rule right the first term that I
will get and carrying at that time
derivative is d LD x times the XD whoa I
said it wrong I'm sorry I didn't mean a
T there I meant a lambda that's what I
mean good I can even call it out with a
different color right so when I do my D
by D lambda derivative using the chain
rule the first term is 2 L DX DX D
lambda the guy I have here but I have
the second dependence in the Lagrangian
the X dot and when I carry out that
derivative it's the L DX dot DX dot d
lambda why do I like that I like that
because notice that D by D lambda of the
Lagrangian is equal to zero in the case
that we are talking about asymmetry and
my assumption is that the transformation
X goes to X of lambda is indeed a
symmetry so what we now have then is our
proof that this quantity called I does
not change in time its derivative with
respect to T is equal to zero that's
what we mean by having a conserved
quantity and invariant quantity and we
have gotten this conserved quantity by
starting with a transformation that
leaves the lagrangian invariant which is
what we mean by symmetry and that gives
us via the proof that we've just looked
at a conserved quantity called i dl DX
dot DX d lambda and that's the proof
that's how we go from a symmetry
continuous symmetry transformation to a
conserved quantity now again this is in
a very special simplified setting no
this theorem applies regardless of the
number of particles and number of
coordinates it applies to
lagrangians that are not for particles
but are for field so it's a very
powerful general result
which I've now shown Yuna the simplest
possible case that if you have a
continuous symmetry that yields a
conserved or invariant quantity now
beautiful beautiful result but let me
finish up by just giving you a couple of
examples often people in the comments
asked me if I could just give some
examples so these abstract ideas perhaps
can be made a little bit more intuitive
and this is a instance where giving
examples is particularly easy to do
so let me oblige and do so so let me
look at example number one consider the
following transformation that X goes to
X of lambda which is nothing but X plus
lambda all we're doing is taking a
physical system in this case a particle
removing it either to the left or to the
right we're translating it by an amount
lambda lambda positive it goes one
direction lambda negative it goes the
other direction so imagine that our
physical system is invariant under this
transformation this is a continuous
symmetry of our theory what is the
corresponding conserved quantity well
for that we just need to go to know
there's general result we take DL DX dot
and multiply it by the XD lambda so you
look at DL DX dot times the X dot d
lambda now the X not the X dot e lambda
DX D lambda now the X T lambda is
particularly simple here because since X
of lambda is nothing but X plus lambda
this quantity over here is nothing but 1
so our conserved quantity is just the L
DX dot what is the L DX dot we'll just
scroll with me back over here DL DX dot
is the momentum so the conserved
quantity in this case is
the momentum P now does that make sense
to you well yeah it does if the system
has no dependence on where it is that
means it's not being acted upon by any
external forces remember if there is an
external force forces come from minus DV
of X DX and if there is an external
potential that is varying say with
respect to X so it has a nonzero
derivative that means the system will
depend upon X that potential energy
function changes depending upon the
location along the x axis if it doesn't
change along the x axis which means
either the potential is constant or take
that constant state to be zero there
will be no force if there's no force
then the momentum doesn't change right
Newton's second law F equals the PDT no
force no DP DT no DP DT no change in P
over time P would therefore be conserved
indeed will be our invariant quantity so
there's a nice simple example where
translation invariance in space
yields momentum conservation let me do
one more example example number two just
to do a little bit more complicated
example let's do an example in two
dimensions now I only derive things for
a single X say in this expression single
X dot but the generalization is so
straightforward that I'm just gonna
write it down and you can recognize
immediately that it is the
generalization so what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to consider a system
and let's imagine that the system has
coordinates say X 1 and X 2 some
physical system and imagine that the
system is rotationally
in variant right so if I take my
coordinates x-one and x-two and say I
rotate them right oops that's a little
funny so let's say I rotate not a very
good drawing over here let's say I
rotate my system through some angle
theta
imagine if the system just doesn't care
it's completely insensitive to its
angular orientation in this
two-dimensional space it's completely
invariant under that transformation now
what would that transformation look like
well you know I could write it down as
x1 x2 right as a little column vector
imagine this guy is rotated and the
two-dimensional rotation matrix you may
know what that looks like but let's
write it as cosine lambda minus sine
lambda sine lambda cosine lambda acting
on X 1 X 2 this would be what we mean by
the vector X of lambda and I'm going to
choose lambda to be small the angle that
I call it theta over here I'm just
calling lambda in my transformation
matrix since ultimately I'm going to
take a derivative respect to lambda I
can choose lambda to be infinitesimal
just to make my life a little bit easier
and for very small values of lambda you
may recall say from our episode on the
most beautiful equation the Euler
identity that you can do a Taylor
expansion and cosines and sines
hopefully perhaps even know this without
the episode itself but I'll write down
the result that you get for small values
of lambda to first order
cosine lambda is 1 the land that
dependence doesn't start till 2nd order
and I'm going to be taking the
derivative around lambda equal to 0 so
that term will drop away sine lambda
that just gives me a minus lambda sine
lambda also to first order gives me a
lambda and again the cosine gives me 1 X
1 X 2 and therefore this is telling us
that X
one goes to X 1 minus lambda X 2 and X 2
goes to X 2 plus lambda X 1 just doing
that little matrix multiplication so
this is my infinite towel in Venetta
simal version of that continuous
rotational transformation and now I'm
going to assume as I said my system is
invariant under this transformation what
therefore is the conserved quantity
well the conserved quantity we know what
that looks like is DL DX dot DX D lambda
in the 1d case in the 2d case what is
this equal to
well 2d I just do DL the X 1 dot DX 1 D
lambda plus DL D X 2 dot DX 2 D lambda
and now this is something I can easily
plug in so the LD X 1 dot that gives me
P 1 the momentum in the one direction
what is the X 1 D lambda well I get that
from right over here it's nothing but a
minus X 2 so x minus X to the DL D X 2
dot that's the 2 component of a momentum
what is the X 2 D lambda well that is
nothing but X 1 and therefore I can
write this as X 1 P 2 minus X 2 times P
1 that is my quantity that is invariant
it's conserved it won't change in time
because of the assumed invariance of my
system under this transformation under
this rotation now what is this quantity
called I physically well if you've taken
basic physics you will recognize this as
nothing but angular momentum
and so what we have learned in this
simple two-dimensional example if we
have a system that's invariant under a
rotation then the angular momentum of
that system is conserved does that make
sense it does because being invariant
and not depending on the angle means
there must not be any external twisting
force right just as in this case for
linear momentum the system being
invariant under a translation meant that
there is no force external force acting
on it in this case invariants under a
rotation means there's no angular force
no twisting force no torque acting on
the system and if there is no torque
acting on the system no angular force
then angular momentum will not change it
will be conserved so that's a nice
second little example that shows us know
there's theorem in action but you know
just to finish this up you have this
very beautiful result that we now have
relating symmetries and conservation so
this is really what it is right here
that if a Lagrangian is invariant under
a transformation come on let me scroll
thank you so if a Lagrangian is
invariant on this kind of a continuous
transformation its symmetric under it
then this quantity will not change in
time that is the beautiful powerful
not--there's theorem that we use in
classical mechanics use it in quantum
mechanics we use it in quantum field
theory you can substitute instead of
particle positions you can put down
values of fields in a Lagrangian that
depends upon fields and in this way
we're off and running in terms of
getting this powerful notion of
conservation laws emerging from now a
turn of the crank understanding of the
underlying dynamics you give me a
Lagrangian has any continuous symmetry I
turned the crank and I extract a lot
amino there
a conserved quantity alright so that is
what I wanted to cover today no--there's
theorem hope you get the gist of it in
these simple examples easy to generalize
powerful result but that is your daily
equation for today until next time take
care